العديدين
الحريه
وكرامه الانسان كلها تاثرت وباشكل اكثر
الاشكال دمويه
امنه اوروبا مهدد
وكذلك قيمنا الديمقراطيه
ومع ذلك كان العالم
حتى مع كل المناظر الجماري هذه
لنا ان نسعد بوحدتنا التي نرجو فيها هذا
الغزو دفاعا عن اوكرانيا وعن السلام وعن
الحريه
[تصفيق]
اظهرت دورا قياديا
اكبر مانحين اوروبيين لاوكرانيا وقد
استجبنا بشكل حاسم واتخذنا القرارات
التي كانت ربما تبدو مستحيله في السابق
قرار المانيا
بارسال هذا الدعم العسكري الكبير
لاوكرانيا
يعبر عن الشجاع البالغه ونحن منتمين جدا
لكم لذلك
يحلقون في عمليات مشتركه فوق دول البلطيق
الحليفه
جيشنا وجيش المانيا
اسست كتيبه
برمائيه مشتركه
وسنزورها لاحقنا اليوم
ان المانيا هي الامه الوحيده في العالم
تجمعها وحده فريده مع بريطانيا
وهذه شهاده للشراكه التي نستمتع بها
ايها السيدات والساده
من البريطانيين تجمعني علاقات شخصيه وطيده
هنا
وعلاقات عائليه
وحتى علاقات تعود الى عده اجيال
ولكننا جميعا
هنالك
نقاط ارتباط عديده جدا وتجاربه مشتركه في
القصه البريطانيه الالمانيه والتي يتكشفت
عبر الفيتين
عبر العصور الوسطى
فن البضاعه والتجاره من لوبك
الى موانعه في كافه الشواطئ البريطانيه
اسست شراكه تجاريه توضح وتعبر عن ازدهارنا
المشترك الذي حققناه حتى اليوم حيث نقلت
البضائع نقلت الافكار ايضا وكيف اذهن
شعوبنا
ببعضها البعض